استسلموا وانقذوا ارواحكم وهذا اخر انذار
لكم هكذا خاطب الجيش الروسي الاوكراني
وروسيا تورط الولايات المتحده بمجلس الامن
الدولي وتشيك تسلم اسلحه لا تحتاجها الا
زالت الاسلحه تعمل واشنطن تبادر بالاتصال
بموسكو انا مضمون هذا الاتصال بينما بوتين
يبشر بنشر اسلحته النوويه على حدود الدول
النيتو والغرب يحبس انفاسه صحفي امريكي
يفجرها كارثه سياسيه تقترب من الولايات
المتحده وتضرب راس بايدن و400 قتيل
اوكراني بهجمات روسيه خلال اقل من 24 ساعه
واليابان توجه طعنه بواشنطن والصين ترحب
والاقمار الصناعيه تكشف عن خطه كم الخبيثه
وصفعه سعوديه روسيه للدول الغربيه اما
الموت في السماء السوريه فهو الوان واليوم
يواصل الكيان الاسرائيلي قصبه لسوريا صفعه
روسيه للمجتمع الغربي
ضربتان في الراس
اذا تكررت الضربات على هدف واحد
الاوكرانيون يتلقون ضربات مكثفه وهنا لا
زالت المعارف العنيفه تدور في مدينه بخموت
وقوات فاجنر باتت في عمق مركز المدينه بل
انها تخترق دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه
لتصبح على بعد مئات معدوده من الامتار عن
المبنى الاداري للمدينه وفق موقع العسكري
الروسي فهل من رد اوكراني قريب ام ان
المدينه ايله الى السقوط لتاتي الاجابه
عبر طائره درون للجيش الروسي والتي القت
منشورات على مواقع تابعه للجيش الاوكراني
في مدينه
دعيه اياهم للاستسلام وانقاذ ارواحهم من
الحرب وفق وكاله ريان بوستي الضربه تتوالى
على اوكرانيا وهذه المره تتسلم روسيا
رئاسه مجلس الامن الدولي لمده شهر ليعقد
الرئيس بلاديمير بوتين اجتماعا مع الاعضاء
الدائمين في مجلس الامن الروسي الاسبوع
المقبل بحسب ويعلن وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني
ان اوكرانيا تعتبر تولي روسيا رئاسه مجلس
الامن الدولي لمده شهر صفعه في وجه
المجتمع الدولي فهل يحقق بوتين اهدافه عبر
المجلس وبحضور الغرب مجتمعين لتتحقق
الصفعه الروسيه حينها ليطمئن مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيفوري الاوكران ان الاتحاد سيتصدى لاي
انتهاك من جانب روسيا خلال توليها رئاسه
مجلس الامن الدولي
لا يتوقفون وها هي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تعلن اسقاط وتدمير 11 مسيره اوكرانيه
وتصفيه نحو 400
وسط تقدم القوات الروسيه بكافه المحاور
حتى ان الوزاره الروسيه اعلنت تدمير
طائرات 29 على الجبهات الشرقيه لاول مره
منذ وصولها الى الجيش الاوكراني لكن هناك
من يجهز دعما جديدا للاوكرانيين للتصدي
لضربات موسكو المكثفه حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع التشيكيه ان لديهم معدات عسكريه لا
يحتاجونها ويمكنهم ارسالها الى اوكرانيا
بينما لم تحدد الوزاره التشيكيه هل هذه
المعدات لا زالت في الخدمه ام خارجها
ابداع يا عم هو انتهت تشتري الوزاره
التشيكيه تتدارك موقف الاسلحه القديمه
وتطلب السلام معلم بانه لا يهم من الجهه
التي ستنظم محادثات السلام حول اوكرانيا
سواء كان الغرب او احد حلفاء روسيا غرابه
مواقفكم يا هؤلاء ترون مع الراعي وتاكلون
مع الذئب فقد بداتم دعمكم بخرده من
الاسلحه انهيتم حديثكم بطلب السلام الهاتف
يرن نعم هنا انتوني بلانك ياخذ سماعه
الهاتف ليتصل بنظيره الروسي لافروب حيث
كان الحديث سريا وتسرب منه فقط الى
الاعلام الغربي خبر حول بحث بلينك معروف
عن حل لاعتقال الصحفي الامريكي ايفان ليرد
ان على امريكا احتراما قرارات السلطات
الروسيه ومن الصراع على الهاتف الى
التحضيرات النبويه لروسيا على الارض حيث
صرح السفير الروسي لدى
لانه سيتم نقل الاسلحه النوويه في الى
الحدود الغربيه لدوله الاتحاد لتعزيز امن
البلدين يضيف بوريسنا الرئيس بوتين امر
بتجهيز منشاه تخزين لنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا لقد قالها بوتين لن
اتراجع عن هذا القرار يا ساده اذا فكيف
سترد واشنطن الجواب الامريكي جاء على لسان
الصحفي الامريكي المرموق سيمور هرش الحائز
على جائزه
بتوقعه حدوث كارثه سياسيه وشيكا للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن تهز مضجعه بسبب تفجيرات
خطوط انابيب سيل الشمالي رشاد واكد ان
الوضع الاقتصادي في المانيا يتدهور وفي
رايه بعد ان فقدت صناعه الالمانيه الغاز
الروسي سيكون العام المقبل وبالا عليها
واشنطن تتلقى طعنه غدر كما نقول هذا دائما
في السياسه لا عدو دائم ولا صديق دائم
السياسه في تتبع المصالح يا ساده ويبدو ان
اليابان ادركت ان مصالحها مع الصين لا مع
امريكا وهي الدبلوماسيه تخرق جدار
التوترات العسكريه بين اليابان والصين
بوصول وزير الخارجيه الياباني الى الصين
ليقول وزير الخارجيه الصيني ان على
الجانبين الصيني والياباني اتباع التوافق
الذي وصفه بالمهم لقاده البلدين وتعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه لازاله التدخلات
والتغلب على الصعوبات مضيفا ان الولايات
المتحده استخدمت اساليب البلطجه لقمع
صناعه اشبه الموصلات اليابانيه بوحشيه وهي
الان تكرر حيالها القديمه ضد الصين حسب
قوله ليرد وزير الخارجيه اليابانيه
العلاقات اليابانيه الصينيه لديها امكانات
كبيره للتنميه فهل عاده المياه لمجاريها
بعد هذا اللقاء الاقمار الصناعيه تكشف خطه
انفجرت الاوضاع في العالم وكل يغني على
ليلى وليلى الزعيم الكوري كيم جون الاسلحه
النوويه وهي صور الاقمار الصناعيه تكشف عن
تحرك نووي كبير في كوريا الشماليه بعد
اوامر زعيم البلاد وتشير الصور الى ان
مفاعلا تجريبيا يعمل بالماء الخفيف في
موقع يقترب من الاكتمال والانتقال الى
حاله التشغيل بحسب مركز ابحاث النوم
الامريكي فما الذي تخطط له ايها المجنون
الاحداث والتطورات وزاره الطاقه السعوديه
تعلن ان المملكه ستنفذ تخفيضا طوعيا في
انتاجها من
يوميا لتنضم اليها الكويت والامارات وعمان
والعراق فضلا عن روسيا ليصل تخفيض الانتاج
لقرابه مليون ونصف المليون برميل يوميا
بدءا من مطلع مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه
العام هنا سترتفع اسعار الوقود في العالم
وفي امريكا خصوصا فكيف سيواجه بايدن هذه
المعضله وجهت القوات البحريه الايرانيه
تحذيرا لطائره تجسس امريكيه في بحر عمان
في منعها من الدخول دون تصريحها ومنعتها
من الدخول في اجواء البلاد سوريا تتعرض
للقصف لتصبح ساحه للنزاع الايراني
الاسرائيلي الامريكي ويدفع الشعب السوري
فواتير الجميع بينما من جهه اخرى وبعد
مقتل اثنين من المستشارين العسكريين
الايرانيين في غارات اسرائيليه بسوريه
تعهدت الخارجيه الايرانيه بالرد المناسب
روسيا تضغط بقوه على الغربي وعلى الاوكران
فهل تكون مخبوط هي اولى نتائج هذا الضغط
الروسي
[موسيقى]